demi lovato who is
a hollywood celebrity i don't even
really remember what she's known for but
she has gone off the deep end in recent
years
she has just gone viral
again
for
spreading all kinds of kooky ideas about
aliens
and about
the universe and about the energy man
you know and the vibrations and people
are making fun of her and she's
radically changed her appearance in
recent years and she is is indulging in
all of these strange
sexual ideologies and new agey type of
religious views
but what's even crazier
is that demi lovato
is no more nuts
than your average secular liberal today
demi lovato goes on some show i don't
know what joe was and explains
her encounters
with the supernatural
i decided to sing for them
and
they went off when i finished i never
had
a standing ovation from ghosts i love it
but i'd like to think there was the
standing elevation with my feels is
ultra
you've made contact i have made contact
it's not been in like the et phone home
type of sense but
i have made contact by meditating and
looking up and seeing things in the sky
that weren't there when i started
meditating so now that you've made
contact with et's
maybe not this kind of contact yes yes
not yet but if there was an et
that hit every box of criteria that
would be like the most ideal partner
like would you date an e2 yes absolutely
i'm so tired of humans
i am so tired of humans and they're
human bull
i am so over it i like me an alien
yes
so a lot of people
watching this are are saying don't do
drugs kids not even once this is your
brain on drugs not even
i think that that's a good argument
but i'll go further than that
i don't think that demi lovato is
especially nuts
certainly not by the standards of
hollywood but i don't even think she's
really especially nuts by the standards
of our
secular liberal culture
i think a lot of people believe the
stuff that she believes
i think if you she might be a little
more open about it and she's going on tv
shows about it but i think if you polled
your average
millennial girl in
l.a or some liberal place
and you said hey do you believe in
in aliens
probably you'd hear yes i do believe in
aliens
of course it's a big universe we're not
so special of course there have to be
aliens out there okay do you believe in
ghosts and spirits oh yeah yeah man
because i'm not really i'm not religious
you know not religion's bad man but you
know i'm spiritual you know i'm really
spiritual so i don't you know i don't go
to church but i go to yoga you know and
i meditate and i'm really and i have
crystals and i'm in touch with in my
horoscope you know i'm a libra with an
ascending scorpio and i was born at the
hour of the moon on if and you know
mercury's in retrograde so what that
means is that the universe man is
putting out vibes and you'll hear this
crap for hours if you go to a party in
l.a or
maybe a little less so in new york
people are slightly more grounded in new
york but austin i don't know san
francisco you go anywhere
where the
secular liberal culture is
vibrant or
as vibrant as it can be
you will hear this kind of stuff
okay this
watered-down new age weirdness
and it reminds me that while the secular
liberals
believe that religious people christians
especially are superstitious
most superstitious people in the world
actually it reminds you
we are the least superstitious people in
the world
traditionally religious people tend to
be the least superstitious people in the
world because
contrary to the spiritual but not
religious people the people who take
religion seriously apply rigorous
systematic thinking to their religion
thomas aquinas was not spiritual but not
religious right thomas aquinas applies
rigorous logic to his religious views
and and discards certain views that were
popular at the time and goes further on
other views
this is true of all
serious theologians
there was a great there is a great meme
i saw going around of uh someone
who was uh in swimming in the ocean and
had a fishbowl on his head
and the fishbowl said religion in the
ocean said spirituality
and my my friend posted this meme and he
said
uh oh you mean that the the glass allows
you to see things more clearly actually
puts glass actually puts things into
perspective yeah i guess that is what
religion does
this stuff is much more pervasive and
and i think that uh
we
rather than just uh laughing at the most
extravagant people who push this this
kind of craziness maybe we ought to take
a look at ourselves and examine our own
beliefs
and think hive
maybe my views aren't so different from
demi lovato's and maybe that's a problem
and maybe i should start thinking more
seriously
about the universe man and my place
in it glad you like that clip hold up
ring that bell
ring it
ring it then you'll get the
notifications and actually sometimes you
won't get the notifications because our
dear friends at big tech don't always
love to give our subscribers the
notifications that's why you got to go
over to apple podcast spotify stitch or
google play subscribe to the michael
knowles show m-i-c-h-a-e-l-k-w-l-e-s
s-h-o-w subscribe leave a five-star
review we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]